in 1980
i came to united states pursuing my
master's degree
1982 i started
selling five dollars digital watch in
the flea market
if i make twenty dollars a day
i was happy because twenty dollars to me
is i have a food and gas money
[Music]
i met my wife in flushing
we're both working very hard
day and night and selling gold jewelry
in the flea market
we opened our first jewelry
and water store on long island but i
have a vision
my vision is flushing flashing is
largest chinese community in the east
coast
chinese are very loyal membrane
and they are spending buying
luxury goods so 10 years ago
i had an opportunity to open a
large-scale
jewelry store on the downtown flushing
today i'm very proud of my three
children
they run in the day-to-day
business growing up i saw how hard like
my parents worked
and i saw how much like their business
meant to them and how much they put
into it that it made me want to like
help them out
i graduated from carnegie mellon
university and the business was really
starting to pick up
to where it is today so i joined at that
time
to help out and i never really left
after that
it's been really a blessing in disguise
to work with my family
just because you developed these really
raw and honest relationships that you
mostly
won't develop if you weren't working
with your family i remember one day i
was driving
to work and i got a call from my dad
he's like hey
you know derek um would you consider
like coming back home to new york
because i was in florida at the time
and i was like okay like what's going on
and he was like oh you know
your mom lisa she just got cancer
i remember like pulling over and i i was
like crying in my car and then
i just emailed my boss right away like
hey i got a family emergency i got to
head home
i stayed home with my mom to help take
care of her and unfortunately in
december of 2015 she
passed away from a rare cancer i got to
see like
through her life like how much energy
and work she put into the business with
my dad
and if i don't come into the business it
would have been for nothing like i
i can't let that happen because you know
my mom's not asking me but i should do
it because it's the right thing now
[Music]
so definitely there's a generational gap
i mean we always butt heads like almost
every day
i feel like you have your moments where
you fight and you're just but like
when you fight it's different from
fighting with your co-workers or
something it's just more like
it's your family but then maybe 10 10
minutes
later you're like you forgive each other
and you're like okay i'm calm
i understand what you say you know we
always joke with my dad he's like
you know when i was your age i used to
do everything in the store and we're
always like yeah but dad
now we're like doing everything you did
plus we have the speed of the internet
of people reaching out to us contacting
us everything is like
much faster yeah i think he's definitely
more open to new ideas now
i think the goal for us is to just do it
and if it's a seize then he's open to it
and if it doesn't succeed then we try
something else
new video tonight showing the moment a
man shoved a 52 year old woman to the
ground outside a bakery in queens
causing her
to hit her head so hard she needed at
least a half dozen stitches we are
chinese
but we are also american and
we work here we work hard we pay taxes
we are american it's definitely been
really terrifying to see all the crimes
that's on the news
and it's really heartbreaking to see
the attacks especially on the elderly if
i ride the train i'm really worried
and i also think not just for other
people but like
if something happens to someone am i
prepared to jump in
we see celebrities like we see daniel
day kim and olivia munn they're coming
together and talking about stop asian
hate they have huge voices and i think
that
not just from them but also from our
local community like stores like us who
need to speak up
we've been here for a long time and
we're part of the history of this
country
and that what we bring is pretty much
our culture and our food and
you know all the good things that
everyone loves to experience and we just
want to get back to that time
especially as an asian american you
don't really see many
asian american jewelry stores that
actually get passed down through
generations so
that's something i definitely want for
our family and for this community
and also like there's been so many
restaurants been
coming up and like a lot of people have
been discovering like flushing and
flushing
growing bigger as a community so it's
been great to see that and i
think that our store has definitely
helped make that impact to
make all the changes the new teams that
are coming in this is my american dream
i want to be successful and i want
my children continuing
running the business make a carrot and
call more powerful
and make a customer happy that's our
goal
i don't think i've ever told him but my
goal for him is i want him to live
comfortably and not worry about
work or anything and just let us take
all the stress and worries
you know he works so hard and he
deserves to just enjoy his life
[Music]